>> Tucker: WILAM THOMAS WAS
A COLGE SWIMMER, HE WAS PRETTY
GOOD, PRETTY SMA, TN HE
STARTED IDENTIFYING  A WOMAN
AND BECA GREAT.
T A SCAM OR ANYTHG.
NOW HE'S NOMINAD BY THE
UNIVSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA ATHE ""
HERE'S A MAN COMPETING IN WOMA
SWIMMING COMTITIONS AND
GETTING AWARDED FOR IT.
MPETING FOR THE UNIVERSITY O
KENTUCKY AS A SMMER AND A
WOMAN D NOMINATED TO BE THE
NCAAOMAN OF THE YEAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMG ON.
WODN'T THIS BE EASIER TOIDENTIFD
DOMINATE KIDS SMMING?
>> THAT SOUNDS ABOUT LIKE HOW
IT'S GOI, DOESN'T IT?>> Tucker:E
FUN OF IT, BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
ELSE TO SAY.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
IF THAT'S EXALY WHATT IS,
IT'S A MOCKERY AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS WHOLE THI TURNED INTO.SOMES
DEDICATED OUR WHOLE LIVESO
SOMETHING PEOPLE ARE LAUGHING
.
IT'S AINSULT AND INCREDIBL
DISHEARTENING.
QUITE FRANKLY, IT'S WRONG.
>> ESPECIAY SENDS SWIMMING,
GOT TO B THE MOST PAINFULF
ALL SPORTS.IF PAIN TOLERANCE ISA
LOT OF SFERING IN THE POOL.
YOU SPENT YEARSND DURINGHIS
AND SOME GUY JUMPS AHEAD OF YOU.
ARE U BETTER ABOUT IT?
>> W HAVE A NCAA WOMAN OF E
YEAR, 9 OF THE LIFE AS A MALE.
IT DOE'T ADD UP.
IT'S JUST INCREDIBLYNSULTING.
DESERVING FEMALE ATHLETE
ESN'T GETHE NOMINATION AND
THOM DID QUITE LITERALLY AFTER
ONE YEAR, IT MAKES SSE BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN ONE YEAR.
THOMAS SPENTS A FEME.
YEAH, IT'S INSULTI AND IT'S A
PUNCH IN T GUT, A SLAP TO THE
FACE ANDOTAL REGRESSIONF
WHAT TLE IX STANDS FOR.
IRONICALLY ENOUGH, T LETTER I
GOT FROM E NCAA TODAY, I GOT
IT AS I'M WALKING OUT OFHE
DOORO COME TO THE STUO BUT I
PICKED IT UP.
IT SAYS THAT TS AWARD IS
ROOTED IN TITLE IX.
IT'S ROOTED IN TITLE IX.THE 50TF
TIE IX, NCAA WOMAN OF THE YR
AWARD OFFERSN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR WOMENO REFLECT
ON THE IMPACT OF WOMAIN
INTERCOLLEGIATE SRTS.
I JUST READ THIS AND HONESTLY
LIKE YOU SAID I LAUGHED BECAU
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING AT THIS
INT IS LAUGHING AT WOMAN.
Tucker: IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE
THE UNIVERSITYF PENNSYLVANIA
AS A JOKEND IT HASEEN FOR A
WHILE, MT PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
AT YET.
YOU FIND IT IERESTING THAT
KENTUCKY WHERE YO HAS TAKEN
A STAND FOR BIOLOGY WHERE TS
IVY LEAGUE SCHL IS TAKING
STD AGAINST BIOGY?
FOR SURE, IT SAYS SOMETHING
ABOUT THE CONFERENCE.
IT SAYS A LOT OBVIOUSLY ABOUT
THE IVY LEAGU BUT FOR THEM T
NOMINATE ME AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
KENTUCKY, WE HAVE AMAZING FEMALE
ATHLETES.
WE'VE GOT ABBY STEIN, RYAN
HOWARD NUMR WNBA DRAFT PICK.
I'VE ACCOMPLISHED GREAT THINGS
AS WELL BUT I DO THK THAT THIS
IS A LITTLE BIT STRATEG ON
BOTH PARTS.
>> Tucker: THE TAKE AWAY FOR
APPEARANCE, THE CHOICE SENDING
YO KID TO PEN OR KENTUCKY,
SE